there is now a big race on globally not
just in China and Hong Kong to develop a
vaccine against curve in nineteen there
are at least 70 potential treatments in
development three of them at the
clinical stage which is when human
trials begin outside China the u.s. is
the only other country now doing human
testing but some experts warn against
rushing the process they say doing that
could result in a vaccine that weakens
our body's ability to fight off the
virus on its own America's top medical
expert Anthony pouching has said a
vaccine could be ready within 12 to 18
months while health officials elsewhere
say it could take even longer let's talk
to John Nichols he's a clinical
professor of pathology at the university
of hong kong his team was the one of the
first outside of mainland China to
reproduce Kovach 19 in a lab for
research he joins us on skype from hong
kong john nichols great to have you back
here on the news ah so the finish line
in theory should be at least 12 months
away how do they fast-forward through
that process well normally with the
vaccines you start off with small
animals and then move to the primates
and then to the humans but it seems of
this one that they've gone straight to
the humans which is a very bold decision
on one my say is it risky I think it's
it's very very challenging because
that's why you have to have the testing
and the small animals to make sure is
that safe and that it works I think the
other issue is that you notice that
they're all using young volunteers and
this is actually going to be a big
problem with this vaccine is that
because the most of the mortality in
this disease is in the elderly and in
the elderly they don't mount a very
strong immune response at that's called
immune senescence
so the best thing should actually be to
see what the antibody response is in the
elderly rather than the young so from a
clinical point of view it would be
better if they managed to get a study
group a group of volunteers people in
their 60s and their 70s and their 80s
well that's because that's the target
population which has the highest
mortality because I'm remembered you
know we've got an aging population in
Hong Kong during
only 11% the population was over 65 now
it's 18% so if they're the best use of
this vaccine should be really how much
it's going to be prevents these serious
disease in the elderly and this has got
to be step change through a linear
process I mean it's safety development
efficacy and then approval and that's
got to be approval handed down by
multiple agencies in multiple countries
that's right they do it very confusing
when you've got so many people working
on so many different vaccines everyone's
going to be competing say there's going
to be the best and so then you need to
have some sort trial of comparing
different vaccines so it's going to be a
very big list just cool and also
challenge for all the regulatory
authorities okay and phase two is
randomized testing with some built-in
double-blind analysis that comes back to
you as a statistical breakdown of the
success or failure and I mean some
people are saying Anthony Fauci saying
that process itself can take two years
well that's right vaccines can't be
rushed in because as was mentioned
earlier is that if you rush a vaccine
too much and you get side effects then
that's going to have a really
deleterious effect and we also really
don't know what sense the population
needs to have the immunity or
vaccinations to be effective things like
measles you need about 95 percent so
because we really don't know at this
stage what the proper herd immunity is
challenging to know at what amount of
the population will have to have the the
antibodies either through natural
infection for a meal or vaccination to
be it for it to be really effective I
don't know if you've been hearing our
earlier conversation here on the news
mr. nickles but we have been touching on
this idea of herd immunity
you know you we've got countries like
Spain our easing restrictions Sweden you
could get on a plane if you could find a
plane to get on to go to Sweden and the
restaurants and the bars and the cinemas
they are open because the Swedish
authorities have said herd immunity
that's the future where do we stand now
give us your insight on this where do we
stand on the idea that herd immunity
might provide some sort of cover in a
contained environment
well that's what people are talking
about with this large amount immunity
you've got these people talk about these
immunity passports but the problem is
that right now we don't know the profit
amount of what in the community will be
effective and so I think that's why in
the Hong Kong and other places they're
trying this gradual letting people to
see how much we can actually live with a
little bit of infection a small amount
it's just basically letting out that
sombrero or the flaking out this curve
to a very very long period of time so I
think that's what most countries will be
doing we're just testing the water to
see how much they can get back to a
normal lifestyle without you be ICUs and
the hospital being overwhelmed with new
infections everyone is talking clearly
about the vaccine herd immunity as well
that's a given and also built-in
immunity off the back of that herd
immunity spreading through whichever
country whichever community we're
talking about chloroquine that's the
other thing that people are looking into
in the United States we've had it's it's
been reported we've got dead people in
Brazil because they tried chloroquine
the Swedish authorities the French
authorities are saying no way Donald
Trump the US president is saying
actually maybe give it a go and they are
investigating chloroquine at a
scientific clinical level in the states
as well is chloroquine are possible or
not I think where it's actually the
preeminent of being sort of led by
politics not by science so everybody has
been saying let's get some proper
scientific trials mean the most people
now say the that French trial has done
quite a few flaws and was not really
scientifically valid but the problem is
is that it's being new to this whole
chloroquine is actually being led by by
the politics and so the science is is
playing catch-up so in a normal
situation we'd be doing proper trials we
have the controls you have the subjects
but now it's just you know people it's
so desperate that they're putting it
pushing aside science I'm not a big
believer in the use of chloroquine
because I think the the side effects and
also the you know it's not really been
proven
so and I think the the way in which some
areas are just you know pushing in it
and recommending the population takes as
a prophylaxis I think is very dangerous
especially with the cardiotoxicity which
has been associated with it okay
listen to the professors listen to the
signs listen to the doctors professor
John Nichols we listen to you thank you
so much for joining us again here on
al-jazeera
thank you very much